excited to be here tonight to be able to
talk with you about my new book my first
book if the speech reason hopefully just
the first of many as most of you know my
name is Jeremy Duda and I know many of
you know me as a political reporter for
the Arizona Capitol times
however I've spent the past eight years
you know covering the governor's office
and just kind of delving into the
Arizona political scene politics
especially Arizona politics is of course
a passion of mine but I think those of
you who know me personally know that my
probably my greatest passion is history
and if you've been to my house you've
seen wall after wall of a double stacked
bookshelves full of history books and it
has always been a dream of mine to write
a history book and so I was very
fortunate and that I got that
opportunity last year and the result is
if this be treason now before I start I
want to extend a special thanks to
changing hands bookstore a fantastic
local book store that has a giving me
this opportunity to come here and talk
with you tonight also a special thanks
to c-span which is here recording this
for book TV which is good because it's
also been a dream of mine to be on book
TV so if you know someone who wanted to
come but wasn't able to make it or you
just find me so captivating that you
feel compelled to watch this again
it will be on book TV hopefully very
soon so the original title of this book
was almost treason and I think that goes
a long way towards kind of explaining
the concept behind the book um another
thing I think that probably helps kind
of explain it a little is our recently
ended presidential election I don't know
if you noticed but it was a very
contentious affair certainly the most
contentious presidential election of my
lifetime and treason was a word that
probably on a daily basis of you are on
social media you heard being thrown
around applied to both major party
candidates to their supporters and I
wouldn't blame you if you didn't notice
it was a low-key affair of course that
will mostly be remembered for its grace
and civility but but so those
accusations did they were flying around
just a bit but when people say treason
what do they really mean you know
treason is defined in the US
Constitution as levying war against the
United States or providing aid or
comfort to its enemies it's actually the
only crime defined in the US
Constitution and the the framers of the
Constitution had a very specific reason
for doing that under British rule which
they were very familiar with treason was
applied to a great many offenses that
were simply you know simply used against
people who were opposing the government
speaking out opposing the king in one of
the cases that I'll be discussing here
tonight from my book there was a Supreme
Court justice who noted that under
British rule treason was not only
raising a hand against the king but just
simply thinking murderous thoughts about
the king and now we saw an example of
that at the Constitutional Convention
one of the delegates when they were
debating this provision mentioned
recalled a case of an Englishman who had
wished death upon a man an unknown man
who had killed his favorite buck
unfortunately for him that man turned
out to be the king and for wishing death
upon the king even though he had no way
of knowing who it was he was convicted
of treason so as I said the framers were
very familiar with the way that the
treason laws could be abused and they
wanted to make sure that that couldn't
they wanted to try and prevent that from
happening in their new country so they
put this definition in the Constitution
so that Congress would not be able to
change it at its whim and it's kind of
use it at whim against people now that
of course has not stopped people from
using the word treason over and over and
over again but most of the times you
hear it such as you know certain
presidential elections or pretty much
any election you know any political blog
anywhere
what's the times you hear that what
people really mean by that is that not
that they are levying war against the
United States they mean that they feel
like someone is being disloyal to the US
they're betraying the country they're
being seditious in some way and so it's
kind of I know when I see it definition
of treason and there was one incident in
particular that actually of that that
actually inspired this book and I'd love
to be able to take credit for it but as
my publishers Alliance Press who came up
with this idea based on this incident
then kind of let me run wild with the
rest of the book you may remember in
2015 just last year
and Obama was trying to negotiate a deal
with Iran to end the country's nuclear
program Republicans were not happy about
how that Jill was going and 47
Republican senators led by Tom cotton of
Arkansas sent a letter to the leaders of
Iran warning him warning them that any
deal they reached with Obama would need
Senate ratification and if they didn't
get that then it could just be scrapped
by the next president if you've been
following the news lately it seems like
a pretty likely outcome at this point
now Democrat Senate Democrats accused
senator cotton of violating an archaic
$17.99 law called the Logan Act which
forbids basically freelance diplomacy by
private citizens and so even went so far
as to accuse him of treason
now the Logan Act may sound a little bit
familiar from our recent presidential
election just a few months ago which I
know seemed like an eternity at this
point you know Donald Trump made a
comment imploring the Russians to
release Hillary Clinton's missing emails
and Democrats said you know that's a
violation of the Logan Act again like
with Senator cotton some said hey that's
treason but um the incident was Senator
cotton I think is a really good
launching point for a discussion of this
book not only because that incident was
the inspiration behind the book because
the Logan Act the law he was accused of
breaking is the focus of my first
chapter I've got 12 chapters plus an
epilogue and as much as I would love to
get into each and every one of them that
would probably keep you all here till
midnight and I think I might where am i
welcomed by then so I'm just gonna focus
on a small handful and I'm going to
start with the Logan act in 1798 the
United States and France were on the
brink of war I was an air time known as
the quasi-war France was at war with a
bunch of its neighbors in Europe and he
was trying to stop neutral shipping from
you know sending goods to his enemies
that unfortunately included us they were
attacking our shipping they were
capturing our sailors and the war seemed
pretty imminent at that point especially
because Congress and the White House
under President John Adams were
controlled by the Federalist Party which
was pretty hostile to France the
Democratic Republican Party led by
Thomas Jefferson very Pro French and
very anti-war but they were in the
minority
out of power didn't have a lot you know
not a lot they could do about it
so in the midst of all this there was
one Democratic Republican who thought
maybe he could do something about this
he wasn't a congressman or anything like
that he was a Philadelphia doctor named
George Logan he was no he was a
democratic Republican a friend of Thomas
Jefferson personally he was a Quaker a
pacifist very Pro French and he thought
if he could just get to France and
somehow meet with France's leaders he
just might be able to kind of talk them
back from the edge and keep his country
out of war so George Logan you know he
was a pretty prominent person in it you
know in his day but certainly no one of
the stature that you would imagine would
be needed to go and actually negotiate
with a foreign country's leaders it'd be
kind of like one of you taking out a
second mortgage to you know go to Iran
and try to negotiate a better nuclear
deal this is basically what he did he
you know it's been his own money he
actually sold several parcels of land to
finance this trip and he went to France
and he actually was able to meet with
France's leaders he got an audience with
the leader of the French directory you
know by this time France had to kind of
seen the wisdom of walking things back a
little bit to they realize another war
wasn't exactly what they needed at the
time and so it's in kind of impossible
to determine what George Logan's real
impact was but the French certainly to
saw they they certainly thought there
was a lot of impact they for his attempt
to come there and make peace he was
hailed as a hero who was a guest of
honor and state dinner as he became a
celebrity in Paris now you would think
that he would probably receive similar
treatment back in his home country for
going out of his own initiative and
trying to make peace that was most
emphatically not the case the
Federalists were outraged they viewed
this as inexcusable interference in
America's foreign policy and by someone
with what they viewed as very dubious
Pro French sympathies as well you know
they basically viewed that many of them
anyway basically viewed the
democratic-republicans as kind of a
fifth column seeking to import to the
atheistic mob rule of the French
Revolution to America
and so they wanted to do something to
make sure that someone like George Logan
could never do this again
and with that ended up being was the
Logan Act is a law they introduced in
Congress that makes it a crime for a
private citizen without authorization
from the government to correspond
directly or even indirectly with a
foreign power over any dispute or
controversy involving the United States
now this has turned out to be pretty
much one of the most worthless laws ever
passed by Congress and I know that's a
very high bar but they might have said
it back in 1799 when they passed this
and you know more than you know
something like two hundred and twenty
five years since it was passed not a
single person has actually been
convicted of violating this law and only
once has someone actually been even
charged with it that is a distinction
that belongs to Kentucky farmer named
Francis Flournoy you know Becker in 1803
he felt the and stop me if you've heard
this anytime lately but he felt like the
political elites on the eastern seaboard
were out of touch with the rest of
America and not paying attention to
other Americans needs so in the absence
of any New York real estate moguls to
vote for in an upcoming presidential
election he decided he was going to
write an article under a pseudonym in a
local newspaper calling for Kentucky and
other western states to secede from the
union and form a union with the French
territory to their west that this is
shortly before the Louisiana Purchase of
France still controlled all that land
the local US Attorney you perhaps a bit
overzealous saw this and decided this
was in direct correspondence with a
foreign country indicted him under the
Logan Act now there isn't a lot in the
historical record about this case
because it was obviously very flimsy
from the start fell apart very quickly
and never went to trial was dropped
before ever going to trial so while the
Logan Act here is a penalty of five
thousand dollars in up to three years in
prison the worst penalty that Frances
florida-y ever faced was to become a
historical footnote for authors like me
as it turns out the only thing that the
Logan Act has ever actually been good
for is accusing your political enemies
of violating it we saw that in the past
couple of years with you know Tom cotton
and Donald Trump facing his accusations
from the Democrats just a few years
earlier
congressional Republicans made a similar
accusation against Nancy Pelosi for a
trip she took to Syria in the 80s we saw
the Reagan administration make these
accusations against Jesse Jackson for
trying to get back American hostages for
Jim Wright the Speaker of the House who
helped negotiate an end to the
Nicaraguan civil war the Nixon
administration thought about filing
charges against Jane Fonda for her trip
to North Vietnam some critics even
accused Ross Perot of violating it when
he was trying to get Missy an American
servicemen back from Vietnam after the
war ended and obviously nothing has ever
come from any of this now as as we see
from George Logan who had nothing but
the best of intentions having good
intentions is absolutely no protection
from being accused of treason which is
very much an accusation you face from
the Federalists in Congress they
denounced him on the Senate floor
basically as in earth as a traitor and
he's actually not the only person who
found his way into my book for trying to
make peace the other was a man named
Nicholas trist
now triste did not betray his country or
government so much as he betrayed his
president which of course under the
British was kind of one in the same and
there actually is no question that he
betrayed its president I think he was
quite open about this but whether he was
doing this in the best interest of his
country is a completely other matter in
1847 we were in the middle of a war with
Mexico and at that point we had marched
very far south into the country
conquered a lot of territory and
President James capo decided it was time
to make peace on extremely generous
terms for the United States of course so
he and Secretary of State James Buchanan
sent tryst to Mexico as a peace envoy
they wanted him to negotiate a peace
deal they gave him a set of terms that
he would have to abide by there's the
minimum that Polk was willing to accept
which was a border at the Rio Grande
River in Texas and basically all the
land that were staying down here today
the land that we ultimately got and then
there's a few other concessions that he
wanted to get
you know we're particularly important
and you know how much he was he was able
to pay the Mexican government for this
land was depending on how much he was
able to get now tryst seemed like a very
safe choice to send to Mexico he was a
loyal southern Democrat he was a very
loyal subordinate to Buchanan he was the
second in command at the State
Department and he was a very strong
supporter of the war which was very
controversial he turned out to not be
quite as safe as President Polk and
thought once triste got to Mexico
who's kind of appalled by what he saw he
basically viewed it as an unabashed war
of conquest and an abuse of power by the
United States felt very ashamed of what
his country was doing to Mexico and so
he was having some serious misgivings
about this war that he'd supported then
he was supposed to negotiate an end to
now at this time you know Mexico was
losing the war badly but they did not
want to sit down at the negotiating
table they were no they were proud they
wanted to fight they wanted to keep
fighting even though where they were
losing so finally they got to a point
where dress was getting kind of
desperate to to get them to the
negotiating table there was a temporary
ceasefire and General Winfield Scott was
on the outskirts of Mexico City ready to
invade tris wanted to stop this from
happening and in order to get Mexico to
the bargaining table he started offering
a little bit more than President Polk
would have been comfortable with he
offered them the harbor of San Diego
which was very important to president
pulk that he obtained that he offered a
neutral zone between the two disputed
borders and nothing ever came of this
but word eventually got back to
Washington and President Polk and
secretary of U cannon heard about this
and they went through the roof they very
quickly concluded that sending trysts to
Mexico was a huge mistake and
immediately recalled him back to the
United States you can to cinema letters
that return to Washington immediately
now by the time this happened the
prospects for peace had actually
improved a little bit a pro peace
faction had taken over Mexico's Congress
and they were ready to sit down and hash
out a deal trysts didn't want to lose
this golden opportunity he was also very
Serna but what was going to happen in
Mexico if he left at the time a lot of
folks in Washington had some very grand
designs about what more they might be
able to take tryst wanted to stop this
from happening so he made a very bold
decision he decided he was going to
disobey his president he was going to
ignore this order to return to
Washington basically illegally negotiate
a treaty with Mexico and bring an end to
that what he viewed this very horrible
war now
Triss knew that he couldn't negotiate
anything that would resemble a fair or
just treaty but he could negotiate what
would essentially be the least bad
treaty with Mexico and stop any more of
their land from being taken stop the
country from being you know further
dismembered he knew it would have to
still be accepted by Polk and by the
Senate which had to ratify it but he
could try to mitigate the damage quite a
bit the result of this was the Treaty of
Guadalupe Hidalgo which was eventually
accepted by the president's ratified by
the Senate and gave us this land where
we sit now for this book reading Polk
was furious but the treaty was good he
it was basically too good a deal to pass
up he couldn't pass up it gave him
everything he wanted basically so
despite how angry he was with his envoy
triste he accepted it he sent it to the
Senate and it was ratified now at the
time as I mentioned there are a lot of
people in Washington he wanted to go a
lot further
some of Polk's allies in Congress and
even some of the members of his cabinet
started thinking hey he could get a lot
more out of this war which basically was
a war of conquest you know some people
wanted to extend our border several
hundred miles further south to where it
is today though that wall are a new
president wants to build or be going up
a lot further away from us than it isn't
it than it will be now some people just
wanted to annex the entire country and
there's really no way of saying that any
of these things would have happened
there are a lot of other circumstances
in play you know the Whig party which is
very hostile to the war effort had just
taken over the House of Representatives
a group that included a young one-term
Illinois congressman you might have
heard of named Abraham Lincoln and they
were pretty keen on just defunding the
war effort and halting the war
together and even some of Polk's allies
in the Democratic Party they weren't so
keen on taking more land - not out of
any sort of sense of altruism but mostly
out of just sheer racism they didn't
want to bring that many new non-white
citizens into the United States so it's
hard to say which faction would have
ultimately prevailed abandoned if they'd
had to fight thus out but we can't say
for sure is that because of Nicholas
trist and his decision to just disobey
as president we never actually had to go
down that road and have that debate
now several of the chapters in my book
you might notice follow a common theme
and that theme is the suppression of
free speech and First Amendment
liberties obviously as a journalist this
is a very personal subject to me and
there's a lot of chapters that involve
journalists not actually because I am
one but because in a lot of these
debates where people are accused of
treason they kind of end up in the
middle of them for various reasons and
even sometimes facing suppression from
the government but as you know usually
when we see this it is almost always
done in the name of national security
and we see that from the earliest days
of our country to the modern day first
time we saw that was in 1798 with the
Alien and Sedition Act which was the
Citizen Act was basically passed for one
reason and one reason only which is to
crack down on the democratic-republican
press that was hounding the Federalists
I have a chapter on that we saw this
again in the Civil War when Lincoln
really cracked down on dissents
you know in the States and I explore
that through the story of Clement
Vallandigham a know high former Ohio
congressman who was a leader of the
anti-war Copperhead faction of the
Democrats Lincoln actually exiled him to
the Confederacy for speaking out against
him
kind of I think a lot of folks at the
time viewed that very much as poetic
justice we saw that as we saw it again
in World War two with the Espionage Act
and the Sedition Act and I write about
how that was used against Viktor Berger
who was the first socialist ever elected
to Congress and was a major newspaper
publisher in Milwaukee but of course no
discussion of the suppression of free
speech and First Amendment rights and
civil liberties in general is complete
without an examination of the McCarthy
era the other of the witch hunts of
Joseph McCarthy and when I started
writing this book or started researching
it perhaps I had I knew I would have to
include something from that chapter just
wouldn't be complete without it and
there's a lot to choose from there is so
many incidents from that time that are
really ingrained in our national
consciousness
I mean think of blacklists loyalty oaths
the house on American Activities
Committee
Hollywood 10 scandal McCarthy's witch
hunts but what I chose to focus on was
something that is for some reason gone
almost completely unrestrained it's kind
of shocking when you see how significant
that miss is and that incident was the
Smith act trial which was a trial of 11
top ranking members of the Communist
Party USA who were basically convicted
simply for being members of the
Communist Party the Smith act was a law
that was passed in 1940 that makes it
illegal to advocates for the violent
overthrow of the US government and it
was passed at the time of course to
target communists but mostly was just
used during nothing against Nazis during
World War two now once the late once the
Cold War started after World War two
things changed a lot by the late 1940s
Harry Truman was under tremendous
pressure from the Republicans who
accused him of being soft on communism
and to kind of rebut those charges he
decided he was going to make in it he
wanted to make an example of some
communists the only question was which
law he was going to use and at the
urging of J Edgar Hoover and the FBI
they settled on the Smith act now
Truman could not have found a less
sympathetic group of defendants at the
time I mean you hear so much from that
era where people who were erroneous
belief erroneously believed to have
you know communist sympathies are
whatnot or unfairly targeted I mean this
these eleven they were just out-and-out
communists very proud and public members
leaders of the Communist Party
you know they pretty much fit the
stereotype that the average American had
of a communist to a tea one of the
defendants was Eugene Dennis who was the
lead defendant and the leader of the
Communist Party USA and he'd been
charged with sedition multiple times
he'd gone into hiding he had changed his
name he'd actually lived in the Soviet
Union twice and traveled the world at
the Soviets s spreading communism in
foreign countries he his wife actually
had to leave their son in the country
because the Russian government said he
only speaks Russian and he's going to
seem too suspicious if you take him back
to America so like I said not an
extremely sympathetic groups of folks at
that folks at that time and perhaps
that's why this incident has been
forgotten when all these others are
remembered so well now the Justice
Department had no actual evidence of
these people plotting to overthrow the
American government by a violent force
but their what their entire case rested
on was the premise that the Communist
Party advocated the violent overthrow of
the government and that by their
membership in the Communist Party they
were inherently conspiring to overthrow
the government even that case was pretty
flimsy but due to a number of
circumstances including just overt
hostility from the judge and a very
bizarre legal strategy that focused
mostly on agitation propaganda and
disruption in the courtroom these eleven
men were all convicted of violating the
Smith act you know they appealed this
all the way to the Supreme Court the
Court of Appeals upheld it they went to
the Supreme Court and it was not a close
call for them there's only two people
dissented it was they decided that even
if these eleven hadn't really been
plotting at the time to you know
immediately overthrow the government
they were gonna get around to it when
they could you know whatever the most
the earliest convenient time for them to
do so that's when they were going to
spring into action and considering
everything going on in the world at the
time this great geopolitical struggle
between the United States and Soviet
Union that these eleven men constituted
a clear and present danger to get to
America as I mentioned there are only
two
justices who dissented one basically
acknowledged that there was kind of no
way for a fair trial considering how
inflamed people's passions were over
communism and the Soviet Union at the
time but hoped that as he put it quote
in kamar times the Supreme Court would
come back and restore the Civil
Liberties was trampling on those kamar
times didn't come for a while it was
actually about six years and and justice
blacks worst fears in those six years
very much came true
once the Supreme Court upheld this
conviction the Department of Justice
basically took this interpretative this
is a starter's pistol to begin an
all-out assault against the Communist
Party USA and it wasn't until 1957 that
the Supreme Court kind of surveyed the
landscape and realized they might have
been made a mistakes and kind of saw the
horrors that they unleashed and they
overturned this struck down as
unconstitutional this conspiracy
provision of the Smith act at the time
but now in those intervening six years
126 members of Communist Party
organizations across the country not
including Eugene Dennis and the original
defendants had been charged with
violating the conspiracy provision of
the Smith act 93 of them were convicted
even after 1957 some of them stayed in
prison for a while even through the
early 60s I think the last defendant was
in jail till 1962 when John F Kennedy
commuted his sentence but interesting
sidenote it was struck down basically in
1957 but the Smith act is still actually
on the books today it hasn't been
enforced in about 60 years but just keep
that in mind if you any of you are
planning to violently overthrow the
America
not talking to anyone in particular well
I think that just about wraps up my
presentation but again I want to thank
you all for coming if you haven't gotten
a copy of my book yet you can buy one
here and at the same time you can
support us like I said a fantastic local
bookstore if you want to learn more
about my book please go to my websites
jeremy duda books calm and afterwards
i'm going to be signing autographs so if
you want to get your book signed
I'll be here signing those before we get
to that I'd love to open the floor up to
some Q&A so if any of you have any
questions about the book in general or
any of the cases I've discussed or any
of the very fascinating ones I didn't
have a chance to get to please ask away
your book do you cover the john adams 0
when he was putting people in jail
journalists asbestos specifically he
jailed Benjamin Franklin's grants and
for pretty good cartoon that made him
look that that is actually the focus of
my second chapter the alien Sedition Act
and specifically the Sedition Act and it
focuses especially on Franklin's
grandson Benjamin Franklin beige and his
paper the Philadelphia Aurora and the
Adams administration used the Sedition
Act very vigorously against everyone at
the paper base was actually dead by the
time it went into effect and I'll be
thankfully so yellow-fever got him
before the Adams administration did but
they folks he let you came after him and
ran his paper after him some of them
suffered some pretty severe consequences
some of the more current events you
mentioned I don't know if this was you
know too soon for the book but what do
you think about the Edward Snowden
situation and how that lines up with
some of these things historical example
well Snowden I think is probably the
perfect embodiment in the modern day of
the concept behind his book he's the
focus of the epilogue not a full chapter
his saga is still ongoing of course and
I'm sure many more books will be written
about it but yeah that's um you know a
perfect example of you hear that you
hear the word treason used
quite often to describe snowed and a lot
of other people call him a hero he he
actually kind of rejects both labels but
while he tries to sort that out he is of
course still living in Moscow or maybe
awareness of treason has changed over
the past 200 plus years um well I think
if we actually you know maybe we would
use the term a little bit less
frequently if we actually saw real cases
of this we have not actually we've seen
I think one case of treason in about the
past 60 years we actually had one in
2006 it was a guy who was doing
propaganda videos for al-qaeda I think
but that was the first one since I
believe 1952 so it's almost a very
foreign concept I think to Americans at
this time and now and by now it's mostly
just something to write on blogs or say
on cable news to denounce your enemies
like I said kind of a kind of an I know
it when I see it standard rather than
the standard that we see set out in the
Constitution treaty was passed and he
went back home were there any
ramifications um nothing good happened
to him now they did not actually pay
unlike George Logan they had no one
passed any laws to stop any future
Nicholas trysts from emerging but
needless to say when he got back to
Washington his job was not waiting for
him when he got back and there was no
government employee man coming for quite
some time which was bad for him because
he'd actually been in the employ of the
State Department for for about 20 years
I think at this point so you know for
many years after that it was actually
very tough for he and his wife to make
it and his family to make ends meet in
1861 when Lincoln took office Winfield
Scott with whom he'd forged an alliance
while in Mexico but actually petitioned
Abraham Lincoln to give him a job but
Lincoln was not so keen on the idea so
wrote out the war kind of anonymously
and then it wasn't until it wasn't until
the late 1860's when Congress even
repaid him for the for the expenses he
didn't kurd while he was in Mexico and
paid them the back pay that he was owed
which James Cape Hulk did not and
finally think
was in 1870 once were around then that
someone convinced Ulysses grants
administration to finally throw the guy
a bone and give him a job and he spent
the last four years of his life as the
postmaster for Alexandria Virginia no
statues or anything you know you'd think
there'd be a couple but there were there
were basically a part of it is like
started I mentioned the free speech and
civil liberties theme that through a lot
of those chapters so I knew each of
those eras that would have to find I
wanted to find one good example from
each and as I mentioned there the Alien
and Sedition you know the Philadelphia
Aurora for that era Viktor Berger the
socialist congressman for the era of the
espionage act in World War one Clement
VII Landingham during the Civil War and
then the Smith act trial others I mean
the the Logan Act was kind of a given
since that was that that whole Tom
cotton incident was the inspiration
behind the book for the rest of them had
to kind of dig deep into my fortunately
large background of historical knowledge
and it took me a while had at a list I
kept crossing things off at adding new
things and finally settled on what I
felt like were 13 very fascinating
incidents wait do you know if any
serious thought adventure of entities in
the Logan Act against Nixon and
Kissinger before the 1968 elections and
I was pretty blatantly obvious mental
negotiation not Kissinger but there was
briefly some talk of using it against
Nixon very brief and her little
background is another chapter in my book
that's about Richard Nixon in 1968 he
was very worried that Lyndon Johnson was
going to start bringing about peace in
Vietnam which would help his a
Democratic opponent Hubert Humphrey win
the election Humphrey was gaining on him
Nixon was basically conspiring to
secretly talk with the South Vietnamese
and telling him to reject any peace
overture from Lyndon Johnson Johnson
found out about this he actually did use
at one point the word treason to
describe this and he was talking to
angrily talking to a senator on the
phone who
an ally of Nixon interesting sidenote if
you listen to Johnson's uh White House
tapes you learned that he snorts a lot
when he talks but he's always that's
something that will always stand out to
me from that research but um they did
LBJ did consider using the Logan act but
they did not fully have the evidence
they needed to go public with this and
at that point he decided that it would
be very bad for the country if this if a
new president was coming in with this
hanging over his head it kept it to
himself
perhaps Americans would have known a
little bit better what they were getting
into had that come out but they learned
eventually Joseph McCarthy that era and
the name Roy Cohn comes to mind did you
write about him because he it turns out
was a big-time mentor to our
president-elect I did not he I think I
believe he got mentioned only in passing
just gonna in the Smith act chapter
talking about a little about the
McCarthy era and the you know haven't
you know have you no sense of decency
sir the famous quote but he really only
gets mentioned in passing this is kind
of a part of that era so one more did
you ever look at me the assertion that
bill Casey went to France and met with
Iranian agents in 1980 to stall the
release of the hostages until after the
election I didn't that was one of the
ones that was a in under consideration
but didn't make the list but that is uh
you know Chris a very fascinating
potential Logan Act situation in and of
itself when you know this and I think
part of the reason this is it's still a
bit murky you know there's a lot of
evidence kind of pointing to that
there's still a lot of people who
believe that didn't happen but William
Casey because you don't know who became
the direct later became the CIA director
under Ronald Reagan he was the Reagan's
a campaign manager I believe and of
course this was all going on during the
Iran hostage crisis just sinking Jimmy
Carter like a stone and that he'd been
trying to negotiate the hostages release
before he left office that's just all he
wanted in the world at that point was to
get these people out and get him back
home before he left office
William Casey might have had a played a
role in that not happening that
basically telling me Iranians to hold
off on doing anything because that would
have made Carter look great just before
this big election and you know
coincidentally or not the Iranians chose
to release those hostages uh within
about a half hour of Reagan's
inauguration they didn't want to give
Jimmy Carter the satisfaction whether
that was because of Casey's interference
or just their own spite towards Carter I
think is still somewhat unresolved but
there certainly have been you know
decades of accusations that that William
Casey did that the Constitution where it
defines treason the following chapters
got some weird language about the
punishments which I just read right
before I came here tonight didn't look
it up about corruption of the blood
being what if the threats against people
committing treason or a limit on the
punishment there is any punishment I
mean execution is you know kind of the
ultimate punishment and a lot of people
have actually been executed you know for
treason it doesn't have to be you know
the death penalty but that you know
there so there really is no limit on how
far the government can go to punish you
if you actually are convicted of treason
it's a high bar to set you have to
either admit it in open court or you
have to have to two separate witnesses
to treasonous acts and that's why I
think this is actually so rare we've
only seen I think somewhere around
thirty cases of where someone has even
been charged with treason in this
country
people have been executed for treason
total uh I'm not sure I think it like I
said about thirty people have been
charged just in total and you know two
hundred and twenty five plus years of
this country's history I think I don't
want don't quote me on this but I think
it's probably around 18 or so have been
convicted a lot of them have been
executed some of them have just spent
their life in prison I know the last
person to be convicted of treason I
think was in 1952 who was a an American
of Japanese descent who'd been in Japan
at the time of Pearl Harbor and actually
worked for a Japanese country company
that used American POWs as basically
slave labor so he was convicted of
treason for mistreating American
prisoners he was sentenced to death but
President Eisenhower commuted his
sentence to life in prison
so they're American citizens typically
are jailed for spying like the
Rosenbergs were executed or Pollard
they're not generally charged with
treason right what what law are they
actually charged under um very often to
see you in the case of the Rosenberg
especially that was the SBI I think it
was the Espionage Act they were charged
with espionage um Edward Snowden another
good example he was charred he currently
is charged under the Espionage Act I'm
sure about exactly a lot of the exact
other statues but there's so many other
laws governing you know taking up arms
against your country and things like
that or stealing secrets as often and
you know things like that passing on you
know national security secrets to the
enemy there's a lot of there's a whole
range of other laws that cover a lot of
these other things what about Daniel
Ellsberg I do get into into him in the
book not not a full chapter but I have
chapter it's mostly about the Chicago
Tribune uh three days before the attack
on Pearl Harbor the paper is very
isolationist and very opposed to what
they saw is roosevelt trying to push the
United States into war they got a hold
of his very top secret war plans for
Germany splashed him across the front
page and there was a lot of talk at
least for a short time of no pressing
charges against the paper and against
its publisher that all kind of fell by
the wayside a few days later the
Roosevelt administration had bigger
things to deal with but the last part of
that chapter probably the last third or
so covers the Pentagon Papers incident
as well and it's kind of a broader theme
for the chapter of press leaks just one
last question that one soldier that was
walked off of his post in Afghanistan
nailed him for five years a lot of
people wanted him charged with treason
for aiding and abetting the enemy
because they're claiming that he went
over there to help them but do you have
any stories or did you have ever hear
any stories of in wartime where soldiers
were summarily executed without trial
for suspicion of treasonous acts or
aiding and abetting in
that's something I didn't really look
into although I'm sure that has probably
you know happened a lot I mean in war
time on the battlefield within the ranks
of the military the commanding officers
do have a lot of latitude to punish
things like that good beer wait do you
think that treason isn't used against a
lot of people because there's so many
other laws they're a lot easier to use
against them that do things wrong
because treason so narrowly define it
within the Constitution itself laws that
have been made no I think that is a big
part of it not only because of the
narrow definition but because the high
bar that's set for actually convicting
someone I meant as I mentioned if you
have two over the two witnesses to an
overt act of treason unless the
defendant wants to admit it in open
court not bloody likely in most cases so
there's a lot of cases where I think you
probably you know at least potentially
you could have brought charges where
that never happened to think of John
Walker Lindh the American Taliban who
gave a very big in the news back up
around the time of 9/11 he would
actually been fighting with al-qaeda in
Afghanistan and was captured by you know
US forces you know he was not charged
with treason and I forget what he was
charged with but George W Bush at the
time very they wrote you know he was
asked about that and he very just wrote
off the possibility of a treason charge
I think he said about this because some
kid who got misled I don't want to do
that so he spent cut since or I think 20
years but no life in prison no death
penalty it could be worse Tom the fact
that the framers thought that treason
had to be treated in a certain way mean
that all these other laws that create
analogies to treason that are not given
the same level of scrutiny if you will
are inconsistent with what the framers
intended to be by having treated in the
Constitution in the first place no I
think that is a very good point as a the
obvious workaround that conference and
Congress has found over and over and
over again is simply passed different
laws that will not for treason so
times could carry the same penalties
that have much lower bar and even some
of the framers of the Constitution he
wrote this found their own workarounds
very early on with the Alien and
Sedition Act which had the concept of
judicial review existed at the time
probably would have been struck down as
unconstitutional but a lot of these
other laws haven't and they've been
brought to court the espionage and
Sedition Acts of World War 1 they were
upheld you know the Smith act obviously
for a time a lot of these things so the
politicians are a creative Bunch and
they've there they have found no
shortage of ways to kind of get around
that very narrow definition all right
well one more chance
and if nothing else then
[Applause]